this house is filled with so many  memories  [Music]  family and is all we got  you are not perfect God knows but we've  survived  because we stick together  and we love each other  [Music]  at the bottom of the stairs I action  film calling this whole thing a crime  scene  what's going on where are the police  looking for We Believe Michael Peterson  murdered Kathleen In Cold Blood  it's Fiction it's fabrication  I got a call from a couple  documentarians it's totally normal  nothing's normal anymore I'm worried  about some things that will come to life  sooner or later everyone's gonna tell  who you are  it's always two things with Michael  Michael that's his name yeah unless he's  pulling Along on  it's my life on the line and I want to  tell my story  and I promise you when we're on the  other side of this things will be better  to La Familia  and to the ones we missed  [Music]